guess what a growing China is not in our
best interest and no one knows that any
more than my next gift joining me now is
Wisconsin Congressman Mike Gallagher
chair of the house select committee on
the CCP Congressman you wrote a
fantastic piece today everyone needs to
read it about how Americans are what you
call Financial backers of the CCP
without even knowing it explain that
well I think one thing we can all agree
upon Democrats and Republicans really
anyone with an ounce of Common Sense is
that American money shouldn't be funding
Chinese military companies companies
that are building things like aircraft
carriers artillery shells fighter jets
Advanced nuclear technology but that's
precisely what's happening that's what
our investigation on the committee of
BlackRock and msci has revealed and
what's remarkable is that these are
companies that have already been flagged
on various government blacklists and yet
the money continues to flow incredibly
it's not illegal but it is suicidal it's
quite literally subsidizing our own
destruction because of course these
companies are building things designed
to kill Americans in a future conflict
if not pointed at American Service
members in the indo-pacific right now
and I can't help but be reminded of
something Lennon once said which is that
when it comes time to hang the
capitalists they'll compete to sell us
the Rope we have to stop selling them
the Rope again it's not Democrat
Republican Hawke versus isolationist
neocon you know verse Dove it's just
common sense I I have no doubt that if
Biden heaven forbid is re-elected those
Trump tariffs that have been quite
successful in holding China back on its
heels those are going to be pulled off
all you need to do is listen to raimondo
uh in the parade of of Biden officials
who've sucked up to China over the past
two months she won't even have Tick-Tock
ban that's not even being discussed the
New York Times is reporting they're not
gonna we're not going to talk about Tick
Tock ban at all despite the fact that
that's a propaganda tool of the CCP as
well
well what's really troubling is just so
that raimondo and before her blinking
Yellen and John Kerry can sit down with
the CCP and get a photo op we delay key
defensive action we make preemptive
concessions just to get to the
negotiating table and meanwhile China
doesn't make any concessions they don't
they don't do anything meaningful to
stop fentanyl flows they continue their
cyber warfare against us it's it sends a
signal of weakness around the world
Congressman look don't you agree that
the Democrats are far more comfortable
and willing to sit across the table with
the CCP than they are in sitting across
the table from the GOP I mean that much
much rather spend time with the CCP
correct
well I think there's a a concern well
there's two things going on in the Bible
Administration one they believe that the
preeminent national security threat is
not China it's climate change if you
read the National Security strategy
that's the white supremacy says exactly
and therefore it leads them to a more
Cooperative approach to the Chinese
Communist party and a lot of this naive
thinking that if we just revive the
policy of diplomatic and economic
engagement good things will happen even
though it's failed for over two decades
I call this zombie engagement we thought
it was dead but it's coming out of the
Grave right now and it's going to haunt
us and of course the risk is that we
find ourselves stumbling into a
confrontation with China that has the
potential to make what's happening in
Ukraine or even previous gray power Wars
look restrained in comparison that's
that's the cost of a misguided foreign
policy and that's what really concerns
me right now with this renewed
engagement push yeah Congressman we
really appreciate what you're doing
thank you very much hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else